today I'd like to talk to you about
puzzling material whose discover was
ridiculed when he found it but in the
end he got the Nobel Prize hi my name is
anissa Ramirez welcome to my lab at Yale
University I'd like to share with you
quasi crystals but in order to
understand quasi crystals we have to
think about space and how patterns fill
space when you go into a bathroom you'll
find tiles on the wall in a repeating
pattern it's their shapes that allow
them to cover all the space some of the
tiles may be square some of them may be
rectangular all them cover all the space
atoms to must arrange themselves in a
repeating fashion just like these tiles
but they have to do it in three
directions we call them crystals these
crystals also must cover all the space
and there mustn't be any gaps Nature
doesn't like gaps the tiles in the
bathrooms not only do they have
repeating patterns but they also have to
have symmetry meaning that one side
looks like the other side this square
tile has fourfold symmetry if I rotate
it 90 degrees it will look exactly the
same there are other shapes with other
types of symmetries as well a triangle
has three full symmetry rectangle has
two-fold symmetry and a hexagon has six
fold symmetry atoms have these
symmetries as well what you will not
find in a bathroom our child's that have
fivefold symmetry or Pentagon's because
when they're arranged like this we will
have space and once again we don't want
space Pentagon's are forbidden
arrangements for atoms as well or so we
thought until Daniel sheckman found a
crystal with one of these forbidden
arrangements he wrote up his results put
it in a journal it was ridiculed no one
believed him he had to work hard to
convince many scientists of what he
found this new discovery eventually with
time he got the reward of a Nobel Prize
so why are these materials so neat well
they changed everything you see we use
atomic arrangements to understand
properties of materials how strong a
material will be how well electricity
passes through it metals are generally
great conductors of electricity however
a quasi crystal metal
not it's an insulator that's completely
different also steels are very strong
materials Kwasi crystal steels are much
much stronger and we don't know why
there's much still to learn about these
materials what we know for certain is
that these quasi crystals break all the
rules and with them the usher in new
materials with weird properties the
Nobel Prize tells us that the way that
we understand materials will never be
the same I'm Aneesa Ramirez thank you
for joining me in my lab at Yale
University and I hope you'll join us for
another material marvel